- Come on, this is some...
My man's been up there
ten minutes.
- Okay, the number pressing now.
No, just hold on a second,
Malia, all right?
Just gotta...
Sorry, everyone,
it's taking so long.
- Oh, my God, Obama!
Obama! How you doing, sir?
- It's me.
Just showing my daughter
how to use the ATM...
Having a little trouble
with the machine.
- Oh, you having trouble
with the machine?
Oh, man, we'll chip in!
We'll chip in right now, man,
- Then you can be on your way!
- No, no, no, no, no.
I'm trying to show Malia
what life is like
in the real world here,
all right?
So just do me a favor,
treat me like you would
anyone else in this situation.
- Okay. Yes, sir.
Yes, sir. All right.
[bleep] hurry up, man!
Is your tie stuck
in the damn machine?
What are you doing, man?
People trying
to get they money up here!
- Not exactly
what I had in mind.
- Go on then!
- Didn't even get your money.
- Dad! Dad!
Dad! Dad!
- Come on, girl, hurry up, man.
You got seven... Oh, okay, no.
Take your time. Take your time.
Take your time.